It's kitten season!
And that means your local shelters are overflowing with cuteness and can use all the help that they can get.
I work with Sante D'or Foundation here in Atwater a lot
and I'm currently fostering a mom and her 5 babies!
Please meet Anime Wong, Lucy Lu, Jet Lee, Jackie Chan and John Choo whos actually not here today
Because it got adopted yesterday! YAYYYY
This mama and her babies and so many more are available for adoption now
So please don't let them down.
And if you can't adopt for whatever reason, shelters always need help fostering
And since it is kitten season, this is the cutest time to foster!
I wanna say thank to audible for sponsoring today's video
especially because all the proceeds are gonna go to Sante D'or Foundation
and help all the baby kitties and the mama kitties and the adult kitties that they have there
So, I'll let them say how thankful they are
[high pitched voice] Thank you so much to audible for sponsoring todays episode
Audible has an unmatched selection of audio books, original audio shows, news, comedy, and more !
Im currently listening to The Handmaid's Tale.
Because it has incredible topical relevance to todays political climate and is a dystopian future not too far off
You can listen when you are cuddling with your mom, running around with your siblings or taking a bath!
For all of you humans, Audible is offering a free 30 day trial to give you a chance to try out their service!
And you can go to Audible.com/Anna to sign up and download The Handmaid's Tale for FREE!
Or another audio program of your choice.
thats Audible.com/Anna